video footage of a cat that accidentally
stowed away inside a glider plane and
then sort of came out and surprised the
pilot it went viral this footage nine
million YouTube views in a day
it's pretty crazy take a look
okay it's crazy the cat I guess was up
there it worked its way and the plane
landed as soon as it could and the cat
is safe that's the important thing
[Music]
who's doing [ __ ] up there's like
kasher died but it's so strange
okay the plane landed at cata safe but
this is a strange thing how some videos
go viral and others they do nothing they
remain completely unseen no one cares I
just don't get it that cat in the plane
video broke the same day as another
incredible incredible video that no
one's talking about a zebra got stranded
on the wing of a commercial airliner yes
he flew all the way from Fort Lauderdale
to Phoenix now get this the flight
included a two-hour layover in Dallas
the zebra was fine at the airport dizzy
but hit the men's room hung out in the
men's room for a while
fever got a more shine then zebra killed
some time browsing magazines at Hudson
news he popped into Brooks home where he
bought one of those net pillows then he
caught his connecting flight Dallas to
Phoenix all the way home
[Applause]
that's a great video but guess what Andy
what all that look coming he views that
one guy forty-six views wasn't that a
great clip subscribe to my youtube
channel for an endless supply of me
[Laughter]